I mean out my teenagers of course like
boy crazy at times Maddie Ziegler made
waves when she posted a photo with her
boyfriend Eddie Benjamin on social media
she's tried to keep her relationship on
the down-low
how long have these two been together
keep watching for 20 things you didn't
know about Maddie's private relationship
before March 16 2020 Maddie Ziegler
hadn't posted much about her current
relationship she hadn't even talked
about it in recent interviews well not
every boy I'm with has to be a boyfriend
so yeah but this was the week that
everyone was trying to feel more
connected to each other on the Internet
due to social distancing Maddie uploaded
a photo of her and her boyfriend Eddie
Benjamin to Instagram they looked nice
and cozy the caption said that they were
sending everyone calm and positive vibes
it was very on brans for Maddie and we
were glad to see Eddie in the pics that
post had close to 2 million likes in a
matter of days Maddie Ziegler is such a
household name these days but her
boyfriend doesn't quite have the same
level of fame yet Eddie is an 18 year
old singer and songwriter he grew up in
Sydney Australia but he moved to the
u.s. to pursue a music career he does
more than sing and write music though he
also plays the bass Eddie posts videos
of his music on Instagram as well as a
few covers of his favorite songs sunset
Epic Records really recently actually
Maddie and her sister Mackenzie are very
close to their mom Melissa Joe Soni is
such a supportive mother and she loves
her daughters more than anything it's
always a good thing when your parents
approve of who you were dating that
definitely seems to be the case for
Maddie her mom commented on the
Instagram photo saying it was a
beautiful picture we have to agree when
a fan commented that the picture looked
inappropriate Melissa was quick to
defend her daughter and Eddie it seems
like Eddie is a mom approved boyfriend
it's not clear exactly when Maddie and
Eddie made their relationship official
but they were first spotted by the press
on December 2nd 2019 the two lovebirds
were out shopping in Beverly Hills
California the press snapped a photo of
the couple holding hands as they walked
down the sidewalk we just loved the way
Eddie is looking at Maddie they are such
a cute pair that same day netting Eddie
posted Instagram stories of their day
out Eddie used to be a member of a band
called
haze trio the van was started in Sydney
Australia back in 2015
their first single was a song called
fire they performed lots of shows at
mini venues they were even part of a
music festival where they played for
over 20,000 people Eddie plays the bass
and does vocals his fellow band members
for Tosh wolf on guitars and vocals and
in the lens declare on drums
Eddie has been trying his band as a solo
artist ever since he moved to Los
Angeles
Maddie has a type when it comes to the
guys she dates Eddie is a musician from
Australia but this might sound familiar
to Maddie's fans one of her most recent
boyfriends was also an Australian
musician dad Kelly was an Instagram
personality who also dabbled in music
online he was from the land down under -
but her relationship with Eddie is a lot
different from the time she dated jack
keep watching to find out how
I always get really like giddy about one
of Maddie's recent relationships ended
in the summer of 2018 she and Jack had
dated for close to two years jack was
famous as an Instagram influencer he got
over a million followers but that's not
how they met Mady and Jack actually met
years ago when they were kids she was
only eight years old at the time
years later they crossed paths and hit
it off fans really loved this couple
together people thought they were in it
for the long haul finish if you love
jack
how do you pin something natty and Jack
had a very public relationship they
posted photos together on their social
media accounts all the time fans loved
seeing how in love they were Jack even
showed up on Maddy's YouTube channel a
few times in one memorable video they
did couples yoga together they did fan q
and a's together too we loved seeing all
the ways they interacted but being in
the public eye was different and it made
the end of their relationship that much
harder in August 20 18 they announced
that they were taking a break a source
close to them told the media that they
were still talking supposedly the long
distance relationship was the main
factor they also both had busy schedules
but it seems like more happened
Matty unfollowed jack on instagram but
the real drama occurred on Jack's end he
updated his Instagram bio to say good
riddance that sure doesn't sound like an
amical breakup to us
Mady regrets how public this breakup
became I'm learning that as I'm getting
older I'm learning oh it's okay to keep
things more private
Maddi and Eddie might not have been
spotted publicly until December but
things already looked serious on
December 16 2019 Matty and Eddie were
spotted at the airport in Sydney they
were flying back home to Los Angeles in
time for the holidays
they took a trip together to Eddie's
hometown did this mean that Maddie got
to meet his family flying
internationally together is a huge step
and so is meeting each other's family
plus it was during the holiday season
which is extra romantic Nadi might be
busy dating but she has a lot more going
on she got her start as a dancer but she
is trying to become a serious actress
recently she was cast as Velma in West
Side Story
this is the perfect movie for Maddie
West Side Story is a musical with a
Romeo and Juliet twist but it's known
for its great music and huge dance
numbers this movie is going to be epic
it's directed by Steven Spielberg and
comes out in December 2020 this could be
Maddie's big break into mainstream films
to work with Steven Spielberg was a
pretty life-changing thing Maddie has
been in several of Sia's music videos
SIA has become an unofficial godmother
to Maddie in June screen 19 Maddie and
Eddie were billed as collaborators on a
song SIA posted as a joke apparently Co
was sick and Maddie recorded her snoring
then Eddie made a 32 second song of it
later he used it to make a rhythm track
is not clear if Maddie Neddy met through
SIA or if they were together when this
happened either way they've known each
other since the summer of 2019 at the
very least
their relationship might be private but
the rest of their lives aren't both
Maddy and Eddie are popular on Instagram
Maddy is a powerful influencer she has
over 13 million followers that's a lot
of fans
Eddie's account is gaining in popularity
as of late March 2020 he has about two
hundred and seventy eight thousand
followers now that everyone knows he's
dating Maddie that number is sure to go
up pretty quickly this should also
really help his music career because
more people will discover his talent I'm
not like well Eddie's career is growing
so is Maddie's she has a very serious
role coming up in the musical movie
music this movie is directed by SIA and
features some of her biggest hits the
movie star is Kate Hudson and Maddie
Kate shaved her head for the role she
plays a sober woman who is also dealing
illegal substances she has custody of
her younger autistic daughter who was
played by Maddie it sounds super
intriguing we can't wait to see Maddie
in such a serious role the photo Maddie
posted of herself and Eddie in mid-march
2020 came at an unexpected time the
people of Los Angeles are already
practicing social distancing but Maddie
and Eddie weren't distancing from each
other they looked very glad to be
together during all of this we hope that
they can continue to see each other and
not have to isolate too much fans were
glad to see that Maddie is doing well
we're stuck
whatever the circumstances of Maddie's
breakup with Jack the distance
definitely played a role he lived in
Australia and she lives in Los Angeles
California but Maddie and Eddie don't
have that obstacle to their relationship
Eddie is living in the Los Angeles area
too they are both busy people so dating
long distance is hard but now they can
see each other more regularly that's
important for relationships to succeed
[Music]
overall the response to Maddie and
Eddie's relationship has been very
positive
Maddie's fans just want to see her happy
the comments on their Instagram photo
mostly said things about how cute and
perfect they are as a couple and we have
to agree that one person said the photo
looked inappropriate because Eddie
wasn't wearing a shirt Maddie's mom shut
that down and said it was totally
innocent fans were also there to defend
Maddie against the haters Maddie's
followers understand the need for
positive vibes
why hazmat even so tight-lipped about
her relationship with Eddie she
explained her side of things to Marie
Claire during an interview she gained a
lot of wisdom with her last relationship
she acknowledged that being in the
public eye caused a lot of issues for
her and that it brought loads of stress
and drama into her life she said she has
learned her lesson she doesn't want to
make the same mistakes with Eddie so
much is already out there in the open
that there has to be some that I want
just for myself
couples who volunteered together stay
together Mady Nettie did some charitable
work back in December 2019 this was just
the day after the first time they were
spotted by the media they joined
Maddie's sister Mackenzie at my friend's
place Mackenzie's boyfriend Isaac
Presley was there too along with several
other people my friend's place is a
great organization it provides services
to homeless youth in the Los Angeles
area it's great that these celebs were
willing to give back in such a wonderful
cause Maddie is all about pause divides
but she also wants to set some
boundaries she wishes fans would respect
her privacy when she sat down with Marie
Claire her frustration was clear she
explained that fans were always
speculating about who she's dating
and asking on her post she said people
make a lot of assumptions but then she
said they need to give it a rest
it's got to be tiring to always be in
the limelight we think Maddie is doing a
great job settling some personal
boundaries in her new relationship what
do you think of Maddie and Eddie's
relationship let us know in the comments
I think it's more enjoyable that way and
yeah it's more precious that way thanks
for watching be sure to give this video
a big thumbs up click subscribe for more
awesome videos from the things see you
next time
you